what i want to
do at this stage
is
spend a couple of minutes going through
some notation and it's just notation
that's all my goal for today is to talk
about notation
and the reason i want to talk about
notation is because this notation is
universal throughout the quantum
community that is mathematically or
almost mathematically no content to this
notation but uh you know
every time you change notation you
create this extra friction for the for
the reader and for the other person that
you're talking to and so it's really
important that we acknowledge that this
uh notation is out there that you are
comfortable with the notation and that
uh you don't see it as an extra level of
encoding obfuscation to getting
to doing
computations with quantum mechanics to
be completely clear the quantum
mechanics that we do when we're doing
quantum information theory when we do
modeling quantum computations is the
multiplication of finite dimensional
matrices by vectors
and uh it's not any more complicated
than that but this notation that that's
been invented the circle kept notation
is
uh
it is in some sense doesn't add anything
but in another sense it does so uh
there's a one particular computational
way in which the kit notation is very
helpful
and that is when you transition to large
dimensional vector spaces so yes you can
work with
ordinary vectors and matrices when
you're talking about quantum mechanics
all the way through but when you start
wanting to talk about
vectors in pi dimensional vector spaces
this ket notation which i'm about to
introduce turns out to be a little bit
more efficient to do that
and if you don't introduce this notation
then you'll end up trying to invent some
proxy for this notation so let's
let's get straight to it and by
reminding you of the postulates of
simplified quantum mechanics so if you
remember quantum mechanics uh simplified
quantum mechanics as they presented it
last time there were six postulates i'm
really going to focus on the first of
those postulates namely that to every
physical system there is a sign to
hilbert space and the hilbert space h is
for us in simplified quantum mechanics a
finite dimensional complex vector space
with an inner product uh angle bracket
comma angle bracket
and just to remind you uh the elements
of our hilbert space are vectors which
are column vectors
uh of complex numbers v j where
v j are complex right and this inner
product angle bracket comma angle
bracket well what does it do it takes
two vectors a vector v a vector w and it
produces a complex number not always a
real number but sometimes a complex
number
um from these two vectors and it kind of
measures the the if you like the overlap
of one vector on the other uh we think
of it in quantum mechanics this is more
measuring probably or being a precursor
to the result probabilities
and the outcomes of measurements
so here's let's now talk about cats
now before i do that uh i'll just
focus on this this inner product here so
i've written the inner product with
angle bracket comma and angle bracket
it's often more more common to see
people write this inner product as angle
bracket line angle bracket and then here
comes the the notation
um
so what does it do it takes it takes one
hilbert one vector out of your hilbert
space another vector out of your helmet
space and produces a complex number
so our i've just changed the notation on
you i i said i wouldn't do that but i
actually did do that i apologize so
actually why don't we just do it like
this we have
a vector space with an inner product
i've used a slightly different notation
for the inner product and there it is
and so
uh here here we actually come to the
origin of the name so the name of cats
um maybe a bit odd but let's look at
this thing that i've just drawn here
it's like a bratket right
there's a bra
kept and there's a c that's been sort of
in the middle
which you erase and then you come up
with the notation bra ket and so now
i'll explain
uh what a ket is in relation to this
particular notation here
so um a lot of authors will just say
a ket is an element of a hilbert space
uh that's just uh you know the way to
understand the notation is that this
this line angle bracket is you really
should be thinking of that as a vector
in many books people say that i don't
like that that's that's no good i'm
gonna raise that straight away i just
gonna have said it so that you will not
be totally like baffled when you look in
a book and you then the authors define a
ket as an element of a hilbert's base no
no no that's actually not the most
elegant way to think about a kit
rather
you should think
of a cat
of of
this thing called a kit as
a linear map
and it's a linear map that goes from the
complex numbers to your hilbert space
this is a only a teeny tiny difference
to defining a kit to be an element of
your hubble space but it's you know it
it has a slightly
um
different uh implementation detail so
what does it do it's a linear map which
takes what does it do it takes a complex
number
zed
and it produces
[Music]
a vector or the vector
uh z which is a complex number times psi
so
where
psi is an element of your hilbert space
so this is really the way you should
interpret um kets
k when you hear the word ket you're
going to hear it you're going to see it
a lot in the next couple of weeks and
probably for the rest of your studies in
quantum computation and quantum
information theory when you see this
word think of it rather as first
selecting your favorite vector psi
and you should then interpret your
favorite vector psi is really just like
a vector in your gilbert space right
here's psi it's an element of the
hilbert space psi and a ket is a thing
that takes a complex number and
multiplies that complex number by the
vector
this turns out to be
kind of handy
correspondingly there is a thing called
a bra
a bra is the other half right and what
is a bra it's also an operator
so it takes it's drawn with this funny
bracket going the other way
i get complaints from my students that
they can't understand my bra and kit
notations so i try and draw it better so
a bra is an also an operator side with
the angle bracket going the other way
where does it go go from well it goes
from h your hilbert's space back to the
complex numbers
and
it's just the adjoin
it's the adjoint
of the
kept
and so
uh
what does that mean it means you can
every time you see a cat and you take
its adjoint
which we introduced in the previous
then it's really
oops the bra
and now um
we are able to
identify
so this is
now connects cats bras and inner
products
we can identify uh
zed
uh
sorry
the action of applying uh bra and then
uh ket so that that makes
the the linear maps right you know so
what is a ket a ket takes a complex
number and produces a vector
and a
uh
a bra takes a vector and produces a
complex number
so this thing here um takes
is a map that takes a complex number to
a complex number
i'll do an example in a second
so we can just define this whole thing
as a right the action of first doing a
ket then a bra
and so which complex number does it take
to which the complex number well it
takes zed your favorite complex number
to
the
number
to a complex number this
and we typically just define
that complex number to be
the inner product
of the corresponding vectors
psi and phi
so
all in all
you can now think of bras and kets
how do i spell summary with two names
right
so browsing kits are really uh
you can identify
oops
bras and kets
with
row vectors
or rather adjoints of column vectors
and
vectors
in h respectively
okay i'll do one little quick example
then explain why we'd bother with this
crazy notation and then i'll hand over
to the head
so we're just gonna just make a maybe
one or two comments and so when you say
vector after the end sign that's also
column vector right that's column vector
oh sorry
absolutely
um and i guess maybe just i mean you
said this implicitly but
right if you have a column vector
there's two ways of thinking about it
you can think of it as a vector you can
think of as a matrix or size you know
number of rows times one yes and that's
exactly the same that you said at the
beginning if you have a vector we can
think of this as linear map from a one
dimensional space to the vector space
right that's the inter interpreting the
column vector as a matrix i just uh many
things michael it's wonderful to have
you here to to to explain that that
subtle point here um
it's
you know vectors uh
we're thinking of vectors with cats
um as linear maps yeah as
uh as matrices sorry
there's matrices
with n rows
and one column
so that's a it's a really convenient
thing to do um
as we'll see as we will see
uh so i will do a quick example like a
super simple example um so here this is
this is a vector
should i tell you first of all what is
our human space our herbert space is c2
so we're talking about a single qubit
and and our and we've got a vector here
one zero inside our hilbert space
um let's call that one
the the
uh we we will typically just write
ket sai
from now on we'll identify
these two things
so when you see ketsa you should really
think in the background there is there
is a matrix with two rows and one column
in this particular instance
and now we can use the
the fact that you can take
superpositions or linear combinations of
other vectors
um to express uh
our cats in terms of uh other ones and
this is where the beauty of the notation
appears
and so i just chose uh a wrong notation
i apologize for that i want to call that
zero ket
so zero ket is is one zero and i'm going
to define one kit to be
um
zero one
and now let's
i'm sorry i'm sorry device yep if you
write it like this now it's kind of hard
to see what you said before we should
not see it as a vector in the robot
space
um you should see it as a
as michelle suggested right you should
look at this this vector here as a
matrix with two rows and one column
so
it it takes a number and produces a
vector right it's a matrix
okay
and uh this notation here is an
identification right
okay
yes and so suppose we have our
our favorite vector inside our helmet
space h psi so that would be like psi
one psi two
uh
where
we have our favorite vector psi one in a
hilbert space so two psi j these are
complex numbers
then how do we express this exact same
thing in kept notation well we can write
psi
it's a linear combination of two vectors
namely zero and one so that's psi one
zero plus psi two one okay apologize
that was a slightly awkward notation so
we will change that to psi zero
and psi 1
like so
and now uh the beauty of this notation
comes when you work with infinite
dimensional hilbert spaces because when
you write your vector elements
you know with these kept notations you
don't have to write out the full vector
and this is the the incredibly important
observation about cad notation so you
know here i'm working in a
two-dimensional vector space and you're
saying well why bother with this
notation like you know vectors are very
efficient way to represent things but if
i have this notation to talk about
vectors abstractly then i can actually
take linear combinations of things
inside infinite dimensional vector
spaces uh straightforwardly so
uh or higher dimensional vector spaces
and then you don't have to write out the
full vector right
because if you're talking if instead
your hilbert space was c to the 1000 or
c to the 2 to the 1000 right then um
you wouldn't want to write out that
vector because that would take 2 to the
1 000 elements to write out
instead it becomes incredibly convenient
to just define uh
representatives for elements for
standard elements of this vector space
and then you work with them
symbolically rather than as writing out
the full vector each time so it's
typically what you have
in in in on in hand with any uh
hilbert spaces you typically have a
basis and you typically have an
orthonormal basis
on hand whenever you talk about
uh
normal
command of the tablet is not optimal
here
so if you have a
uh when you when you introduce your
favorite helmet space you typically come
it comes along with a standard
orthonormal
basis that you can write out
[Music]
and that orthonormal basis you can sort
of describe symbolically is you put a
one in the first entry and you put zeros
everywhere else and that will refer to
as ket i don't know we'll call that ket
one for example
we can then talk about ket two which
represents the vector where you have
zero then a one then zero is everywhere
else and then so on right you can
introduce this long list of kets and now
with that definition in hand you can now
talk about much more complex elements of
this hilbert space without having to
write out the full
two to the one thousand element uh
hilbert space
column vectors
so if you want to as long as as long as
you're you you only consider linear
combinations of a finite number of
series basis elements like that so you
could
you could certainly write this sort of
thing out now j equals one to two to the
one thousand
um and you can specify these objects
uh where these psi j's are really just
the components of the vector but now you
can specify a finite number of them
quite efficiently
and the final
comment to make
apart from the notational convenience is
that we can represent
matrices and operators very efficiently
this way
using
so-called ket bras
so a ket bra is as the name sort of
suggests is a
concatenation of a cat and a bra
so i write them like this
now uh everyone who sees me do that says
psyx5
so what that really
you're going to get used to my notation
on this this is psi ket then concatenate
so that dot means concatenate with phi
so this symbol now has a meaning you can
interpret that
as as a row or an adjoint of a column
vector multiplied by
a
column vector
and that's a matrix right that the rules
of matrix multiplication allow you to
interpret
uh rows times
vectors as matrices
and
you can now take uh
any
operator and represent it as a linear
combination of ket bras
so this allows
to
you to represent
any
operator
as a linear
combination
of ket bras
and i'll do one example and then i'm
done okay
so we'll just go back to our hilbert
space example
of a qubit and now we have an operator
on a qubit what's an operator on a qubit
so an operator on a qubit is a matrix
and a matrix takes
an element of the hibbit space to itself
in our case it's a
by two matrix like this
so it's m one one m one two m two one m
two two right that completely specified
the matrix now
uh where each of these m j k's are
elements of the complex numbers and now
using this kepbar notation and this
standard basis notation so to remind you
of the standard basis
the ket 0 in this particular instance is
1 0 and here we have 0 1.
we can represent this this matrix here
as a ket bra m
is m 1 1
[Music]
2. this makes life easier m one one is
one kept bra one one plus m one two one
two
plus kept two one two one and finally m
two two two two
so
operators can also be
similarly expressed as linear
combinations of
of capras in the same way that browse
can be represented as linear
combinations of brass and so on
now that's
effectively all i want to say uh about
this notation uh at the beginning it's
an extra work for you to work with this
notation you're like vectors are better
you know matrices are better they're
more explicit
but
i could i i now that you've seen the
notation i encourage you to to try and
convert
normal vector operations into this
notation
and then as you gain more experience in
working with quantum mechanical systems
you'll start to see the virtue of this
notation
and that virtue i can't convince you of
until you've had to work with high
dimensional vector spaces so that that's
that's that's something where you you'll
slowly appreciate the
the virtue of the notation but i don't
believe at this point i can declare that
it's a better thing to do
so i think that's the moment where i
would like to
stop talking
and open for any questions before i hand
over to mikey
okay it doesn't seem like i have any
questions
yeah
um when you when you introduced this um
you wrote this row vector multiplied by
the column vector yes
yeah i cannot see why this does not give
only just one number for me this looks
like a linear combination like
thank you it's good that you asked that
question it's the other way around
really yeah all the way around
waiting for a good moment
there you go sorry
questions are good man
okay i wrote total nonsense
there you go that's what i should have
been
being used to writing these scalar
products so much right yeah
yeah
good
okay
if there's no
other discussion
points questions then i will stop
sharing and then i will hand over to
mikhail
who's going to give us the first taste
of quantum
information theory
now michelle can you show your screen or
is that not yeah let me let me just try
one sec
oh yeah that works
[Music]
beautiful this works right you can you
can see my screen
wiggling about
okay can you see my
screen it looks perfect awesome
all right let me
well introduction
we all met each other many times in our
introduction sessions but um it's really
a pleasure to introduce mikhail to you
right now to give this first taste of
quantum computing because mikhail has
had significant experience in the past
years he's really one of the leading
algorithms the quantum algorithm
developers worldwide
and he's had significant experience
actually teaching quantum computing to a
wide
diverse audience i think that's fair to
say right
and so i'm really i have a yeah i'm
looking very much forward to your
introduction today
great thanks thanks device yeah hi
everyone uh great to have the chance to
also talk to you in this format um let
me just rearrange all the screens
uh fantastic yeah please interrupt me at
any point with questions um
[Music]
so i guess i wanted to give you sort of
a general introduction to quantum
computing um i probably prepared more
than what we have time for and i think
it's more important to
focus on the concepts and take take
things slow also for myself um uh so i
you know i'm sure there will be time to
continue at the future today so we don't
have to get to any particular point
today but what i want to discuss is
basically um
well give you sort of a flavor of you
know what do quantum algorithms look
like and a simple example where a
quantum algorithm does something more
efficiently than a non-quantum or how we
say classical algebra so that's the plan
for today uh before that maybe though
i'll just take the opportunity to
play a little bit around some more with
these cats so just make some comments on
what device was saying
um
you know sort of like i studied pms so i
think
it's okay if i say that you know
sort of
it's completely fine to think of cats as
vectors and you know as fast as co
vectors or the zero vectors
um it is it is very nice from a
conceptual perspective to think about
them as as functionalist as linear
functions the way devices described and
it's actually something like i was also
saying before we automatically do right
if we see a grid of numbers and it has
one
it's a single column we in our heads we
all the time switch between think of
this as a vector depending on the
context or as a is a matrix right
somewhere that's not even a difference
for us usually we don't even think about
that but if one writes it down
mathematically that might arise exactly
what the topaz device was explaining
before
um i guess the way i i think of these
cats is also um and i think also in many
papers that you you maybe have looked at
or will look at in the future uh you
also just uh you know see people
basically using this notation um
and just putting some arbitrary label in
the middle okay
so they may for example write you know i
don't know maybe in a classif in a
classifier they would just write cat
nice okay so that's just the vector we
call it that nice vector it corresponds
you know to some
vector
but it doesn't matter what it looks like
right it's just important that we gave
it a name okay so that's one comment so
in particular i mean tobias explained
you know that usually when we have a
qubit
with the cat zero vector and we have the
cat one and i will write equality signs
not tildes because for me they're really
the same thing
um
but there's another those two vectors of
chrome they form a bases right so like
devices explaining any vector can be
expanded as a linear combination of
those but of course there's many more
bases of c2
and there's another basis that's very
popular sometimes called the hadamard
basis
and you know it looks as follows there's
the oops there's the 1 1 vector and then
we normalize it to have no one and the
one minus one vector right you see that
the inner part between those two is zero
so they orthogonal they also have norm
one because they divide by one over root
two
um and this basis as i was saying is
usually called the hadamard basis
automatic basis
this is called the standard or the
computational basis
and we'll see that actually it's very
powerful and something that we cannot do
with an ordinary bit that you can switch
between these bases in some sense that's
where all the magic of quantum
computation will come from
now why do i talk about this now in the
context of the scat notation uh well
the the reasons that we also use this
funny cat notation and this very
standard way for denoting these basis
vectors usually this is also called the
plus minus basis so what we would do is
we would take a plus and put a cat
around it
and take a minus and take a cat around
it now where does this notation come
from well because this vector is one or
root two times
cat zero plus cat one
and the bottom one is one over root two
cat zero minus get one right so
the label here sort of focuses on the
important parts do we take a
superposition with pluses or one with
minuses
so i hope that this gives you a little
overview of the scat notation sort of a
very practical but from very practical
perspective please do ask me
right now if anything is unclear if i
made a typo
uh on the slides
so just to follow up on that get
notified the two things happened i just
recall the head notation
and i also introduced a new basis basis
that i think the buyers hadn't
introduced before and of course there's
many more bases but these are the
favorite ones for today
uh maybe another sort of i mean you may
not get can be convinced that this cat
notation is a useful thing
and why do we write cat zero
i mean there's good you already heard
lots of good motivation for it um
another one that i personally like is
you know i mean tobias mentioned cat 0k1
they are basis right so if you're a
mathematician probably you write your
basis as e0 and u1
right that's like a very standard
notation for basis but it's a bit weird
right because somehow there's a lot of
baggage here that's completely
unimportant namely the letter e it's the
same every time and the important part
which is
the zero the one it's a subscript right
so the scat notation it's really
focusing on the important thing the
label and then it's sort of decorated by
the cat or a little flag around it okay
so that's maybe another way to motivate
this notation for me personally now
having worked on this field for a while
it's also really useful to see at an
immediate glance what you know what type
of object i'm looking at when i see a
cat i know it's a vector when i see a
bra and a cat together i know it's a
number
um that's maybe more complicated if we
would write it you know like like
in a more messy way with whatever like
you know kind of just symbols and little
stars without having the flags around
i guess this thing maybe doesn't syntax
check maybe it does you
will not discuss it okay
cool okay so these are just uh two
comments maybe one more comment to
practice this bracket notation one more
time
um tobias explained we can also take
these outer products right we can write
cat times bra and that corresponds an
operator or to a matrix
and he has written down for example
something like that does does anyone
want to
do you know what kind of object well
that that thing is not it's a it's a
matrix right it's a matrix as device
explained uh who wants to say what the
matrix looks like maybe you remember
from
the first uh
part
any volunteers
so imagine we this is a
so we work with a qubit so this should
be two by two matrix
what would that particular matrix look
like
that's right thanks you know and this
would be one zero zero zero
uh now this matrix is not an arbitrary
matrix that's a bunch of interesting
properties it has it's rank one okay
okay so it but it yes
it not only has rung one it's also
hermitian matrix where it's the same as
the ceramic conjugate and it's actually
squares to itself
okay so that means actually the
scheduler browser is a projection matrix
what does it project on on the one
directional subspace spanned by this cat
zero vector
another way to say this if you apply
this matrix to cat one
it just gets inhaled
okay nothing comes out
right so one zero zero zero if i apply
this thing
to one zero i just get one zero back but
if i apply it to zero one
i get nothing i mean this is now not cat
zero but
zero the zero vector vector of length
zero
or maybe i could also write it like so
okay
um and so that's in general that's the
general fact whenever you have a
perhaps like capsize this object sends
psi to itself and everything that's
orthogonal to psi is sent to zero
so this is always a rank one projection
i think that's a very it's a very nice
way of writing a reg one projection
right not as a gigantic matrix not as a
complicated way
so you can immediately pattern match
whenever you see cyber outside that's a
projection onto a vector at a one
dimensional subspace okay
very useful
any last questions about this broadcast
notation before we sort of zoom out from
spend the rest of today actually not
discussing notation but
with concepts
i'll just have a simple
it's actually a nice exercise maybe for
you to think about and you can ask me
about it to verify that this is a
projection whatever vector you well
whatever unit vector you put in
okay
very cool so do remember the spaces it
will come back
perhaps today
uh for how long should i be going so i
think i was uh i think tobias meant to
be done a little bit earlier but i think
we spent a lot of good discussion
actually
should i stop at four or four thirty
what's the four would be really short
because that's like 15 minutes
um what what i mean you should have a
feeling like
what's a good
yeah i think 430 should work well um
i think 4 30 is is enough because then
then people start to to get tired
when you see me going into this position
you know that
um yeah it's time yeah i mean something
would also be an i'm not sure if we had
brakes before but this would also be an
optimum moment to have a five-minute
break because now actually we start from
a scratch but maybe we had such a soft
start that i should just keep going so
maybe if if you would like a break you
can raise your hand and if i don't see
hands being raised i will just
continue
it's not another way
very good everyone seems to be getting
to learn about chronic computing so uh
that's fantastic so so let's get started
um so
what we'll do well actually it will take
us a while to actually formulate a
quantum algorithm because we first want
to talk about some computer science
concepts okay and i'll want to start
from the very beginning what's the goal
of you know algorithmics and complexity
theory so i mean one central goal right
is to solve computation problems and
then we have to say okay what is the
computation problem we don't want to
solve them in an arbitrary way saying by
writing down formulas but we want to
solve them by algorithms and we want to
find algorithms that solve these
problems as fast as possible okay maybe
we won't even know how fast can that be
done
so i'll take the time to write that down
okay so in cs
computer science
we want to solve
problems
by algorithms
um yeah and just colloquially as fast as
possible
and of course it's not clear what all of
these words mean of course many of you
will know they will have some
preconception
um what's a computation problem right is
it to find something is it to
show that something exists um
there's many options right uh to prove a
theorem um
i mean all of these are valid answers
but they correspond to different kinds
of problems uh it's also maybe not so
given algorithms it's not a python
script is it you know something written
in pseudocode is it a touring machine
that's programmed in a certain way is it
a circuit
um there are interesting nuances between
these or differences between these
concepts and then the last point is the
notion of fast okay i wrote
fast not efficient because efficient
sometimes has technical meaning
fast can also mean many things right
efficiency is a more general term can
also mean many things can be
using little time using little
computation resources
lots of lots of options and it of course
depends on the model that we look at
okay
so that's of the space in which we're
going to work and i'll try to make these
things very concrete as we move along
give lots of examples
and the goal of hopefully today if not
next time will be to
give you a bunch of simple computation
problems they may look rather contrived
but we'll sort of you know start with
very contrived ones and then move
towards actually very practically
interesting ones very general ones
simple problems where content algorithms
can really rigorously give an advantage
so we can understand that and why uh
they work faster than any possible class
alarms okay and making that precise
that's going to be the goal making that
clear
so today
let's go
um hopefully today
yeah simple problems
uh where quantum algorithms i always
write q and not quantum
i give an advantage
so that's sort of a first attempt
actually what we want to do today and
we'll be able to phrase it more of if
more precisely in a moment
so first question um okay like the
quantum part is of course important
uh the first question maybe that you
might ask and i think that's something
you have maybe have not discussed yet is
actually what is what is a quantum
algorithm what does it look like
so i think you have now a very nice
introduction to the laws of quantum
mechanics the accents of quantum
mechanics
um you know the scat notation you know
what gates are uh tobias i think also
exchanging measurement i'm sure as a
notion what happens when you measure
qubits
so you know all these building blocks
but what is an algorithm
so that's maybe the first question i
want to discuss a question
what does a quantum algorithm look like
and i don't want to give you a very
mathematical definition i want to draw a
picture and make some comments about it
so that's the first question
oops
okay
um
so it turns out that um in quantum
algorithmics we
on computer science we usually like to
think in terms of circuits which
something that seems very low level and
very i may be unfamiliar you know for
those of you who have been in a
classical computer science class
although if you have been in such a
class maybe you think back and probably
what you did is you did learn about
turing machines and states and
transitions and automation and so on and
those are also very low level if you
think about it right and a lot of the
low levels of course because we encode
you know things that we run reasonable
integers for example like some binary
fashion and then we compute using
logical elementary operations and so on
so forth so the same is true in the
quantum realm and uh for us it turns out
to be more convenient to think about
circuits okay so what does such a
circuit look like
um so we start out with a bunch of
qubits okay and we all initialize them
in this zero state
so um for me uh the lines the horizontal
each there will be horizontal wires like
in a circuit
each of the wire each wire corresponds
to a qubit and they're all initialized
in this cat zero state okay so that
means that the whole hilbert space which
is c2 sensor c2 tensor c2 lots of c2s is
in a state that's cat zero tens of cat
zero ten circuit zero and so on okay so
there's little tens of product signs but
usually we don't draw them okay we don't
we don't denote them
so we it's basically saying i'm you know
initializing my memory my quantum memory
all in the zero state except there's our
cat around it because it's vectors it's
a vector in the space
okay and then we apply these gates and
these gates as device i'm sure explained
are unitary operations that act only on
a handful of these qubits at a time
usually one or two okay
so for example maybe there's a gate
that's applied to these first two qubits
maybe at the same time we apply a gate
on
the next batch of two qubits maybe then
we apply a certain gate between the
second and third one and maybe this is a
control not operation which you may
maybe have seen this notation being used
if not i'll just tell you and we can
come back to this so this is a also in
cluster computing a standard way of
denoting controlled knobs so that means
you flip this
qubit you know if this qubit is in state
one
so there's a matrix corresponding to
this the c naught matrix is is that
something tobias uh explained
we've talked about a couple of c notes
you know i should have really watched
the video i apologize
then i would be up to speed with uh
for that um fantastic okay very good so
so so we continue right and then
um
at some point usually at the very end of
the algorithm
um we measure okay and i'll denote this
by such a picture maybe we measure the
first qubit maybe measure many cubits oh
sorry this is a terrible so this should
be a little dial okay the dial kind of
doesn't make sense because the answer is
either zero one that's not actually on a
scale but okay we usually like we like
the symbol
so the outcome of such a measurement is
an ordinary bit zero one
but here i measured the first qubit i
could also measure more qubits okay so
this is sort of three phases but of
course you could continue afterwards you
could say okay i measured the stupid i
got answer zero because i got on the
zero i'm now going to play another you
know for another sequence of gates to
the other qubits then i measure and so
on and so forth but in the most simple
setting that's what a quantum algorithm
might look like so there's a phase
that's trivial where we just initialize
all the qubits
then there's a sequence of gates that we
apply so we apply gates
and finally we measure one or more
qubits
one or more qubits okay and then we
interpret the result
okay
so that's sort of the anatomy if you
want of a simple quantum circuit or
algorithm
maybe i'll say we usually use circuits
consider circuits
this is here so the anatomy
of
simple quantum algorithm or quantum
circuit the way i wrote it but i want to
think of i want you to think of this as
an algorithm because what i imagine is
that these steps they are being done by
some control program by some you know so
there's a so similarly to if you program
a graphics processor for example or
another kind of co-processor right
there's sort of a main program saying
and it's saying now execute this snippet
of code now execute that's in a bit of
code and then you read back the results
but
roughly speaking how gpus were
programmed 10 of 20 years ago
so here it's very similar we have a
quantum processor it's sitting somewhere
in the fridge and we program it you say
okay reset the quantum computer apply
this gate between the first two bits and
so on and so forth and at the end you do
this okay and now um this ordinary
computer that controls that of course
may do select a different circuit
depending on the problem size right if
you have of course you know if you want
to
manipulate very large numbers then you
need more qubits and if you have a small
number to work with and so on and so
forth okay so so what i imagine usually
i mean there's many ways of thinking
about it i imagine that this kind of
picture
is sort of controlled by an ordinary
computer
and when i say controlled i really mean
that you know this the sequence of what
is supposed to happen on the quantum
machine so what i wrote below
oops sorry
but i wrote below that's what's supposed
to be controlled so these kind of things
yeah similar to gpu world and that the
circuit that we actually run
depends
on the problem size okay
hopefully this will become more clear
but you can already ask me now if you
like okay
so but it's sort of clear right if i
want to sort a list that has thousand
elements i probably need you know maybe
a thousand cubits or a thousand times
something many qubits if ever less than
one element it can be a smaller circuit
so that's the way to think it leah
please go ahead um like i have not
really any idea of what holding like
normal computing works or not quantum
computing would say but i cannot really
see from here why should it be different
from not quantum computing because also
fantastic computing you have like some
initial things some gates and then some
right
perfect no you're completely right i
could have given the same picture to
explain what a circuit is what the
circuit model is for ordinary computing
and it was written exactly the same and
the only difference is these little cats
here
that make it clear that so in an
ordinary computer right
this the state space would just be bit
string a bit string of length one two
three four five
in our quantum computer state space very
different it's now states with a c2
tensor c2 tensor c2
tensor c2 tensor one last c2 okay
so that's the on our quantum computer
now in our classical computer right it
would be
bit string so zero one a single bit to
the five
so that's the only difference well
that's the difference in the state space
and then the another difference is in
these operations that we are going to do
it turn if if all you could do is this
control not for example then everything
would stay classical we would always
have basis vectors and so essentially we
would be working with a bit with little
bit strings but since we can do other
matrices makes that create these
superpositions the states that are going
to be created by such a quantum
computation can be very different and
it's sort of we have to understand how
you know how to make use of that so the
important thing is that these the these
gates might create superposition what
you cannot have with regular bits
that's correct yes so if
one precise way of saying it is so these
gates they correspond to unitary
matrices if these unitary matrices would
always be permutation matrices so single
one in each row and otherwise zeros then
they would just map basis states onto
basis states and so essentially they
would just you know always have that
would always be a single bit string at
each point of computation we would not
gain anything
yeah so that's it's a great question you
could also say oh how about
probabilistic computing if you can
introduce randomness the same picture
and the same words i said would make
sense but now the state space would the
state space would be neither of these
two it would actually be probability
distributions over bits which is you
know something like that but with
positive entries
and normalized in a different way
instead of the square summing to one the
entries would sum to one that makes a
huge difference it turns out um so
somehow we'll see we will have to see in
a moment why the minus signs that we can
basically create in our states why they
make a difference so that's that's the
key
thank you
thanks for the question
very good but now
we yeah i think we're on board what the
circuit slash algorithm looks like so
this is a circuit and these circuits are
generated or we can imagine them being
generated by an algorithm and we usually
identify these two things okay having in
mind that there's yes there's really a
family of circuits where we think about
one for each size of the problem
the next question maybe that we want to
discuss is um
uh
how does such an algorithm get its input
okay so usually in a computational
problem there's an input and an output
so a problem that you want to solve okay
so how how do we model an input okay so
one way of modeling the input would be
we just initialized part of the computer
with the actual the question that we
wanna the problem we wanna solve from
instance okay i'll give you a bunch of
examples in a moment but one example
would be suppose you wanna factor a
number okay then you wanna put in the
number at the beginning right i mean or
somewhere you want to put in the number
that you want to factor the algorithm
has to endurance of its input
and that's actually
more than one obvious way to do that and
i want to modulate this by a bunch of
examples okay
and then i want to basically make a
distinction between what we call black
box oracle problems and ones where the
input is given explicitly and that turns
out to be a very important distinction
again that's a distinction we also make
in ordinary computer science but in the
uh in our context it will be very
interesting okay
all right so second question we want to
discuss therefore as i was saying is um
how does an
um
algorithm get its input
how is the input specified
how is input specified maybe
and it's sort of related to that as it
will turn out is how do we quantify
actually when i say con algorithm is
given advantage i have some measure some
quantity in mind that that you know is
sort of better for a quantum algorithm
for a customer so i want to discuss in
relation to the first question
um how we how do we
quantify
the advantage posed by one algorithm or
another one is one other and faster than
another that's basically what i want to
discuss
and
the discussion that we'll have will sort
of correlate these two questions okay
but we'll start with the first one okay
how's the info specified and i just want
to give you a bunch of examples i want
to give you some thing maybe i i
i should call a computation problem but
i'll call it a task which i think of as
a more informal word uh because for me a
computation problem something gets
precisely defined there's input and
desired output and i you know i say the
input should be a bit string encoding a
natural number something like really
precise and rigorous when i say task i'm
just going to write you know sort of
sloppy words
so i i want to discuss with you a bunch
of tasks
so there'll be a little table that we'll
create and for each task i want to
discuss how could the input be specified
what would be natural to specify the
input okay
so one task i want to discuss is the
task of factoring a number
so if a composite number we want to
figure out a a factor okay
a close array problem would be to
determine if a number is a prime number
or not if the prime of it has no
interesting factors okay
so here um it seems like the input is
very obvious um it should just be a num
well it should be a number
we have to encode this number somehow
right because even for ordinary
computers and the whole discussion by
the way that i'll have we'll have now
well
you can ignore quantum for a moment
quantum will come back in full first
later but we're just talking now about
problems not about solutions okay
so the way we specify the problem we
just think about ordinary computers okay
so we want to specify a number and
usually what we would do is we would
write down the number and some system
same binary okay it turns out it doesn't
make a difference whether you specify
numbers in binary or in decimal or
whatever binary is nice because then we
use zeros and ones it would make a
difference if we specified our numbers
in unitary so unary is you know like you
know one tick for each you know if the
numbers of thousands a thousand ticks a
thousand ones
whereas you know if you do binary you
need roughly log thousand bits to
specify the number so this logarithm is
of course a
radical difference but okay that's not i
think that's very i mean i'm not even
sure what i talk about because i think
this is very clear to you uh anyways so
we you we would specify a number so
that's the input here in terms of its
digits and maybe we picked the digits
binary just you know to make life simple
for our computer okay
so this seems sorry so i'll put a
question mark here but really uh maybe
it should be exclamation mark because
i'm not sure what else we should be
doing
okay so that's one thing uh here's
another task suppose we have a function
that's an optimization problem we have a
function maybe a convex function we want
to minimize it
okay
so the input here in some sense is this
function right so given the function i
want to find the minimizer or minimum or
the minimum value
what do you think should be would be an
actual input here for such a problem
maybe any someone has thoughts you can
also write in chat by the way if you if
you don't want to speak up
so the computation task is an
optimization problem a minimization
problem given a function minimize it
uh and now it's maybe not so obvious how
to specify such a function but maybe you
have some suggestions
well the easiest way would would be to
say just a linear functional
very good so you could say we can we can
specialize we can say instead of looking
at a complete general function let's
focus on a specific kind which we can
somehow encode in a natural way
as well as a kind of circuit says philip
yeah yeah that's right so that's also
that's also very nice suggestion right
we could provide a circuit so i'll write
all these things down so we
we could restrict
well let's say suppose our function if
linear
uh then just as a vector right because
then would be so a dot x and d we just
specify the vector
uh if it's a general arithmetic function
we could well if it's a general function
we could specify for example an
arithmetic circuit
or by say a formula right these are very
similar things
so this is one way to do it okay
um does anyone have another thought
how else could i specify here
it imagine you implement you know in
your
in python you implement gradient descent
how would you specify the function that
you want to minimize
you want to implement a minimizer okay
numpy for example right maybe some of
you know numpy
there's a minimization function maybe on
maybe scipy i forget
how how would you do the program
sorry again as a function a computer
program yeah yeah exactly so usually
what we do is you sort of give a
callback function right so we feed our
minimizer actually a function
and
well the minimizer knows nothing about
that function except how to evaluate it
right so if we pass a black box a
callback or closure i mean there's lots
of different terms for this and computer
science depending on community
so so that's another option right so we
basically pass it a
a black box
and so this we can imagine it's sort of
a gadget
we put in a oops we put in a possible
value of x
and out comes f of x okay so maybe i'll
write f into this box okay
so that seems like a very different way
of encoding the problem right now now of
course i mean it's very cool right so
you have it's like a very general way
you don't have to restrict your linear
you don't have to restrict the formulas
it's a very different input model you
just have access to the function and you
know you don't know the function in its
totality unless you ask it questions
unless you put in x value but any x you
can learn f of x but not more okay
uh i mean maybe in the context of
grading the same it may also be actually
natural to give black box access to the
gradient instead of the function itself
but let's just sort of a detail um
another way to think of it of course
would be when given such an such access
here right you can compute the gradient
by finite differences and then you could
for example do great in descent right so
that would be a natural way of doing it
does does that make sense to everyone
does anyone have question about what
what i mean when i write something like
this
right so the idea would really be right
i have a little python snippet oh let's
see a chat
oh yeah exactly yeah exactly before i
show that i only saw you know that
exactly function yeah right you do like
a little def you know gradient descent
uh python thing and then you just pass f
as a function right and then somewhat
inside
inside your grading decentrality maybe
you do a bunch of gradient steps and
then you would actually numerically
estimate the gradient by calling f of x
f of x plus epsilon or something like
that right
so that's kind of the idea so
do you have any any questions about
about what i mean by a black box
function
okay it's really a gadget you put in x
you get out f of x
and it seems extremely natural for for
the problem we're discussing here
here's another um
computational task finding an element in
a list
it's a little bit underspecified what i
mean by this
maybe the element could be
five the number five maybe the element
could be uh something that satisfies a
certain criterion i don't want to worry
about that part what i want to worry
about is the list okay
what how do i you know
provide a list as an input okay
and again there's two options that you
could imagine one is well maybe the
natural runners suppose it's a list of
numbers well we just list this
each element after the other so if the
if the list has a thousand elements a
thousand contains a thousand numbers
the input contains a thousand a thousand
parts and
that these parts are the first number
the second number third number and up to
the thousand number so
thousandth number okay
so the one option would be a list
of and say you know elements
say numbers
one
after the other
but again there's also a natural black
box model right and what would that look
like well it would like look like would
be a database right so basically for the
you would input a location say i want to
know the ith entry of the list
so you put in i and index and what comes
out is well the ith element of the list
say the height number
this would again this would be sort of a
black box way of specifying a list okay
and you can really imagine it's like a
database query right or a table query
it's like you know a gigantic excel
sheet but instead of someone handing you
over the excel sheet you know as a
document you say tell me row row a
thousand okay now tell me row 200. okay
so there's a famous algorithm called
global's algorithm which is about
finding things in a list
and there indeed this is the right model
that we'll be using okay
so why would one like to consider such a
model okay and not this explicit one
well in some sense it's very this is
very uh general and abstract right
because now this black box can be
implemented in arbitrary way it could
make a call to some server it could run
its own level content algorithm inside
it doesn't matter right some box it
gives you the ice element so if you can
provide a quantum speed up for example
for the search problem for this finding
problem in this domain you can apply it
whenever you want to find an element in
some unstructured list okay
and
so that so that's of one point okay
another point is of course
uh
suppose you have you you specify this
list one element after the other then
even just to read this entire thing
right it takes a lot of time
so
just um
i i think this is a really really really
important point and to just just
encourage everybody who's listening i
was really struggling with this for
quite a while when i first encountered
it
because in in classical algorithms when
you do these kind of things
um
for instance an online algorithm there's
a typical thing where you have these
you need to do to make a choice between
some things and
it's always going to be the last thing
you look at that's sort of the worst
case
so
when you think in this classical way
and you look at the lesson the left
option that you're giving here as the
input you look at this he's like
how could you ever beat this this is
impossible
so
looking at this on the right hand side
and and of course the way this is
typically stated in literature it's it's
searching a list
it's just plain wrong
i mean yeah completely wrong so that's
right like it's it's only right if you
have this interpretation mind and not
not the obvious one yeah and i mean
so if you're not meant to understand
grover's album at this point i just
wanted i mean at this point if someone
just discussed that there's even another
option of thinking about the problem
absolutely maybe this black box one and
i i'm just just jumping in here so
people
put that pointer into their minds when
we get to go over and you say like how
can this be
this image that that michael puts up
there it is very different and and it's
it is not looking into a list it is it
is you have this overlaying black box
function
which which is why you can look in
multiple places at once and
that's right yeah and of course i mean i
mean there's more magic like like you're
already anticipating what comes right i
mean we have to i mean i think these
pictures hopefully are very clear to you
but of course now if things become
quantum it's not even clear what these
boxes should be doing and we'll also
discuss that hopefully still today
so anybody who's listening here now
later on
it's not you you hear that once and it's
fine you just
remember this point
yeah please do ask to ask questions as
well yeah
so i wanna yeah can you hear me um
does the
quantum computer have to be able to
evaluate the black box
in this quantum way right or
yeah i mean i think you have something
in mind that i haven't even mentioned
maybe someone else has already spoiled
the surprise for you so so we will have
to talk about what does it mean to be so
this these kind of black boxes we
usually call oracle okay and and invalid
and calling them as we call querying in
oracle and we have to discuss what that
should actually mean in the quantum
world okay and i want to i want to
discuss it very carefully in a moment so
there will be a quantum version such
boxes that seems more powerful than the
classical box the boxes that we've been
discussing so far and i want to argue to
you why nevertheless does not achieve it
makes a lot of sense and but i wanna i
think this will maybe take us time
hopefully we can do it today but i think
it's a very good discussion to have so i
mean maybe allow me to postpone
that question so so
sure
so
but
i mean from a high level point of view
it's the same as the classical routine
right if you in your python program you
write a grading descent minimizer that
great design minimizer just gets you
know this f uh you know this function
you want to minimize and you can call it
whenever and however often it wants to
call it
similarly for a quantum algorithm that
would be the same our quantum algorithm
we'll call these quantum oracles this
quantum black box at various points in
the algorithm
and maybe we want we're interested in
how often do we call the box okay maybe
that's how we measure complexity
or maybe we do it in different ways so
that's i will discuss about this in a
moment i mean for maybe what i want to
do beforehand though is just to discuss
two more examples where again maybe
there's an you know two natural choices
of input so the explicit model and the
black box model uh just to get everyone
on the same page that's all right
i'm sorry i'm not sure if i missed that
point but um
i didn't really get why you you call
that black box is that because you don't
really know what this function does or
that's right that's right so the
algorithm the only thing the algorithm
knows is okay there's a function and
it's a function so you can put it you
can you can ask it in some sense you can
put it x into the box and the box says
oh f of x is you know well it's the
value of the function
but
if we call it black box because it's not
like we get this function as a long as a
big function table okay
so it's it's it's it's you you can think
of it as like an interactive thing right
i have a function in my mind and you
want to know about the function
one option is i just tell you f of zero
f of one f of two f of three the whole
function list now now you're in form
that's sort of the left hand side column
uh the other option is that i say okay
i'm a function and now you get to ask me
questions you you can ask hey michael
what is f of zero i tell you okay it's
five then you say okay maybe now i'm
interested in f of seven okay now i tell
you another so that's the model okay so
for example when you minimize a function
using a gradient and maybe that's
something you have seen then kind of the
only thing you need to know is what is
the gradient at a certain point but you
don't have to know if the function is
linear or if it's quadratic or whatever
so kind of the only thing you have to do
is you have to
say hey function tell me your gradient
at point x and then you know the
gradient you do a little step you update
now you get a new point now i say hey
function what is the gradient at this
new point x prime and so on and so forth
okay
so so that's so the algorithm is
completely agnostic of the inner
workings but of course if you want to
now analyze algorithms we do have to
know maybe if it's a convex function
it's a linear function it's electric
structure and so on
i think you want can i just just add a
picture to this i cannot draw on yours
but suppose i give you this right here's
that interval
okay you see that interval
and and now you
i want you all i'm telling you is that
above this interval there is a function
and the only thing i'm telling you it's
a convex function
so now i let you and these arrows
indicate this
uh
you can you can sort of check and say
like okay what is what is the value of
the function of this now michael was
saying uh you could look at the gradient
and so on but how do you get the
gradient maybe we'll just more
elementary here okay
and now what is above you don't know so
here's here's a bunch of functions they
could all be possible convex functions
right
so you the black box thing means
you say okay i give you an x tell me f
of x and then i'll tell you this
and maybe you have the f of the
the boundaries as well okay like you
know this but you still so there's a bit
more that you know now and now if i give
you maybe and you say like this
um
well a convex function
so now now you have guessed this one
here
look at this right
so now you know these four points
and because of these four points you can
say like oh man
um
i don't even know what the curve is but
i already know that because it's
this it cannot be it cannot be in this
interval
yeah like because you know it's convex
so it's going to get something above the
function then this way and so on yeah so
this is this is uh golden search
classical algorithms where you you take
a sequence golden search means that gold
ratio does good things and so on so on
think about this for yourself a bit
you you get you you get to ask you get
to ask these x's you say like tell me f
of this one and that one and that one
and now you get to determine this the
sequence here and you want to narrow
down where the minimum can be by
depending on the answer that you get
in a classical setting
when you put your mind around this then
then you get into this frame where you
say like okay it doesn't matter what the
f how this f is computed and now i hand
it back to my computer yeah exactly so i
mean i'll give you two two more examples
uh i mean
something that also came to my mind
right this is sort of guess a number
game right maybe i imagine a number
between one and a hundred and then you
can ask me questions you know
i know is your number you know 50 or
something then i say no it's smaller no
it's larger yes it's that number right
then you can sort of zoom in in this way
so this is also kind of it's a bit like
an interaction right and then somehow
the question is
how few questions do you have to ask me
to figure out the right number that's
kind of you know one way of thinking
about this computation problem
different one would be if i just you
know
yeah that's not even it's not even clear
but somehow the black box is hiding
something you actually care about
could be this minimum it could be you
know
uh i don't know the element in the list
like in my example and you want to
figure out by sort of interrogating this
black box or by using it you know as a
subroutine if you want uh in your
algorithm i'll give you two more
examples uh one is uh sorting a list
that one's kind of interesting i think
um and the last one is solving a linear
program
we'll do that in a moment so sorting a
list right of course we already
discussed how to specify a list so this
is a good option that's a good option
so i'll write c above
but here there's also another natural
way to do it because just imagine you
want to sort a list right somehow maybe
it's a list of numbers maybe it's a list
of names in some sometimes you don't
care what the elements are in order to
sort a list all you the only thing you
need to know is
is a certain element larger or smaller
than another one okay so only the order
is important so you could imagine in
this case a black box that you specify i
and j there are two positions in the
list
and the answer is for example say it's
one if xi so the ith element of the list
is larger than xj
and zero otherwise imagine they're all
distinct elements for simplicity okay
so this would also very so this would
would be a way of allowing you to that's
enough information to sort the list
basically any two elements in the list
for any two locations i will tell you
this one is larger than the other this
one is smaller than the other
and then you could ask you know
how how many of these comparisons do i
need to make to sort a list okay so
that's actually how in their computer
science one studies you know complexity
of sorting and how one shows you know
that i know n log n is you know required
so so maybe that's sort of uh another
example and so why is this interesting
um because you don't have to worry about
other what's the type of the elements or
maybe you have a list of data but you
want to sort many different there's many
different criteria that you want to use
maybe you want to sort by first name by
last name by phone number and so on uh
here you don't have to worry you just
specify such a comparison comparative
function comparison function that just
allows to compare to arbitrary elements
okay and again it's in a black box
fashion you don't actually need access
to the list you just need to know given
inj is the highest element larger or
smaller than the json okay
so that's one example
and then the last one i wanted to
mention that's a bit more abstract um
maybe it connects to some things you
have discussed with shundor
so i guess you you guys discuss linear
programs um
as a paradigm somewhat
so a linear program i mean there's many
ways of setting it up but one way to do
it would be suppose you want to minimize
a function a linear function is a c dot
x or c transpose times x subtract two
i'll just say ax
large equals to b
a is a matrix b little b little c are
vectors x is a vector say an rn
and this larger equals means component
wise okay there's just a bunch of linear
inequalities and you want them so so
kind of you have a set of x's right that
satisfies a bunch of linear inequalities
and you want to minimize the linear
function okay the details don't matter
so much
but the general flavor it's a
minimization problem and it has
constraints okay
so how could you specify such a linear
program to your linear programming so
okay the obvious way well it's just we
have what we have a e and c and we just
specify them as arrays of numbers
arrays of numbers okay that would be
maybe the obvious choice okay does
anyone have another thought something
else that may come to mind okay
um maybe this one is not so obvious
maybe i'll yeah i mean if i don't see
anything in chat maybe i'll spoil it i
mean
okay there's no canonical unique answer
but one thing you could do
is uh you could um
instead of you know specifying this
constrained matrix a explicitly you
could have a box that for any x tells
you yes the constraints are satisfied or
no they are not satisfied and i'll tell
you in a moment why that is interesting
but i'll just first draw my picture so
given x right the output could again be
a bit
it could say one
if well the constraint is satisfied and
zero otherwise okay
so when would something like this be
interesting this could be interesting if
there's really lots of constraints in
your linear program right say
i don't know a million is probably not a
lot for shunder but say i don't know
like lots of millions of constraints
okay
so if you have lots of constraints in
linear program you don't want to write
down this gigantic matrix okay but
rather you want to implicitly evaluate
this okay and then there's other
algorithms that kind of only need such
an oracle
for example i mean the one that's not
practical but which i know well is the
ellipsoid algorithm
that can then at least in theory solve
these problems efficiently shouldn't i
go ahead
um i will get back to this point um so
so you can set a pointer to to me and
i'll i'll pick this up you can pass that
ball to me
uh with this uh separation optimization
and all that
so we're working our way towards more
and more linear programming then we'll
do integer programming and and that
comes up awesome let me put one final
point but maybe the high level the high
level point i want to make though is you
have some search space okay maybe this
one's not convex maybe i'll try again
maybe this one well this one's also not
correct but again if i don't want to
draw a sphere maybe take this one just
it makes even sense
so there's two you know there's various
ways of specifying such a shape one is
sort of explicitly that's basically what
happens on the left the other is just
you know yeah some shape and you get to
pick a point let's say i want to know is
this point in it no this one in it yes
this one in it no okay and that's a
black box
okay you can interrogate you this region
by a black box okay
one final one final key word for for
future memory reference
is um
traveling salesman problem and sub tours
but we'll get to that so just so you
that you remember this one because
you sold remember very good
okay um
i'll just summarize what we saw in these
examples in this discussion and you may
ask of course questions in chat or
by just speaking up
so
what i i think we saw in this discussion
right we saw that there sort of
was two and that's a few i mean it's
sort of artificial the way i said that
but there's two natural types of
problems one where the input is given
explicitly right just you know digits
formulas vectors arrays the other is
where the input is given by a black box
or
we prefer the term oracle often okay
so i'll just summarize this so as we see
it's too natural and i think both i hope
the examples made it clear that both of
these are very natural ways of setting
up the problems yeah they're different
but it's not like one is artificial and
the other is you know more privileged
it's just that maybe it's more familiar
to us to think about something where the
input is given explicitly but actually
the writing site is very powerful
because it sort of allows us to you know
build things that can work with
arbitrary subroutines
so the first one part a there the input
is given explicitly
and part b
the input
is given in terms of a black box so
given by a
black box or
oracle okay
explicit it's clear it's kind of all
these examples like this arrays of
numbers
explicit lists digits vectors circuits
formulas all the stuff okay
any any questions about this okay so
this is sort of maybe an important
distinction
good
so now i mean we can maybe so this is
sort of addressing the first problem how
would an input be specified and i mean
both of these models they make sense for
quantum algorithms just like they make
sense for classical algorithms uh this
one seems simpler right when the inputs
give it explicitly in the end it all
binds down to long strings of bits right
we could just put these bits somewhere
here okay at the beginning and we start
computing
okay or we could kind of feed these bits
uh to the classical computer that
controls the quantum one right and it
could inform the circuit that's being
run based on this input okay
but it's a bit less clear how we model
these black boxes these oracles on
quantum computers and we'll come back to
that in a moment okay
before doing that though i want to
discuss the second question about you
how do we quantify advantage or
efficiency or you know complexity of an
algorithm so that's the second question
and that question is informed by the
discussion we just had right because if
you're in explicitly well the only thing
they're going to do is they're going to
apply gates elementary operations you
know that we sort of associate the sort
of
costs of one okay
that leads to what's known as time
complexity in computer science
however if you work in this black box in
this oracle scenario there's another
figure of merit that that we could look
at namely the number of times you have
to ask a question to the oracle the
number of times you have to call the
subroutine in other words
and that is known as query complexity
and uh well it's very natural of course
but often times that's what dominates
costs i mean not in the toy examples
that you'll see in a moment but in
practice right if we
minimize a complicated function the cost
you know is making it's it's natural to
count how many how often do we actually
have to call this function may involve
lots of things but if it's query a
database the database cost will be you
know the query time maybe it's even like
in a different network a different
computer on the network that will
dominate not the little
post-processing you do on your computer
okay
so
i'll write this down um while we met it
while we meditate about it so we
quantify
uh the efficiency
efficiency
or we often say
complexity
so i'm not sure why my handwriting is so
terrible when i write on standing desk
mode
of an
algorithmic solution
or an
algorithm all right
accordingly
maybe i'll actually write algorithmic
solution because
this is all in reference to a certain
computation problem we now discussed
what these computational problems would
look like
accordingly
okay so and sort of in the first case
hey some of the only reasonable thing or
the only thing that maybe comes to mind
is we count the number
of gates
every other circuit mindset or the
number of elementary operations
elementary operations
if we are sort of more in a
code mindset required to solve the
problem
okay and usually there's some parameter
on the problem for example the size of
the list the number of digits in our
number and then we're interested in how
many gates do we need as a function of
the size okay to factor an n bit number
how many
gates how many steps do we need okay
so this is what's known as time
complexity
but if we are in this oracle scenario
there's a second option
where we discard everything except the
calls the queries to the oracle okay i
mean of course we could look at both
that would be complicated again but some
other thing the simplest thing which is
still interesting that we could do is we
count a number of so-called queries
it's just fancy terminology for calls
to this black box oracle okay again
require you know the number of calls
required to solve the problem
okay
and this is what we call query
complexity
okay when we worry about you know hard
things like p versus np then sadly we're
in the left domain
but the right domain is already
interesting it's much simpler it turns
out to analyze and i think
logically this should be green and not
blue okay
and this one is much simpler to analyze
um because we ignore the details we
ignore all these little gates that we
applied we are just counting how often
do we invoke this black box how often do
we query this oracle
and um you know if you think about it uh
off you know for example when we uh
well it's not so clear from this
continuous example that gender and i
discussed but say this numbers game
right where i sort of had a number in
mind that you had to guess
it's really about information right you
make one call to the oracle you learn
something about the function and so you
know each call gives you one bit and so
it's
easy to imagine that there's some more
like you know information theoretic
argument going on there well while if
you get worried about time complexity i
mean you're just you're sort of faced
with the full difficulty of the of the
problem of you know
understanding all algorithms and so on
you can like so that's so that i mean
it's difficult to appreciate if you
haven't done this exercise yourself but
maybe we'll see in a moment why at least
for some problems it's easy to argue in
this query complexity world because it
abstracts away a lot of the baggage
right it abstracts away all the boxes
except for the ones we call this oracle
okay
okay can i say two things um one thing
is it's it's 4 30 but
just to give you a chance
after your second comment so when you
when you think of a game um it maybe is
a good idea to to think of this
separately when you think of a game
where you spend time thinking about what
you're doing
but then you're making specific moves
and you may do
a smart move in some way but you may
have to think about it so so there's a
different way of of measuring these
things that's a fantastic analogy right
i mean just to make it clear and in the
analogy if i understand you're right the
thinking part is kind of all the little
gates we do before we decide
how to query the black box next when the
move is kind of clearing the black box
yeah everybody has sat down with a
strategy game with a chess or a board
game and you think and you think and you
think and then you do something and
that's the query that you're doing and
yep
well that's that's an excellent analogy
it's a bit like you know maybe you're
faced with some complicated chess
situation and you know
scenario a
there we're like measuring how many
hours does it take you to you know i
don't know
beat your opponent and option b you're
asking how many moves do you need to
make you know say in the best case to
beat your opponent and you can think for
as long as you want there's no time
limit
and and sometimes sometimes
it is much faster i mean when you do a
sudoku for instance
you could think of just trying out the
numbers and sometimes it's much faster
than if you just think all the logic or
so on
yeah anyway
uh good stuff yeah so indeed so it's
it's half past so uh
what we managed to do so far just to
zoom out a little bit
so before i promised you that perhaps
today uh but certainly not today we will
discuss simple problems where given
advantage now we can make this a bit
more precise so
one thing we can do is for example
we can say next time
or in a future time
we will discuss a simple
um oracle problems so ones that involve
these black boxes
where quantum algorithms give an
advantage
in query complexity okay
very complex advantage
and
i mean i don't want to just
let you leave without having one
concrete example mine so i'll give you
one that looks incredibly simple
um and nevertheless there will be
difference quantum being classically
okay
and
i call it deutsch's problem because it's
a the problem that corresponds to the
algorithm by david deutsch that's a
special case of deutsche doser
um and yes i want to still present this
if that's okay that will take a couple
minutes and i think then maybe
uh i think in a future session i'll talk
about what is actually
a and quantum arc look like why is it an
okay notion
and how does the solution the quantum
solution work
uh and you know sort of how does it fit
in to the picture what are sort of more
realistic problems okay so this will be
a toy problem so i warn you but
nevertheless it's kind of striking that
you know by changing the games and by
doing quantum we can do better okay
so at least in principle
so
we'll call the deutsches problem
and the promise the following um so the
input is a function a black box function
okay
so
the we have a function and it's a
function from a single bit
to a single bit
there's not so many such functions
there's four functions in total right
there's the function that's always sends
any input to zero that's the function
that's constant one
then there's the function sends x to x
and that's the one that says x to its
inverse okay so these are all the
options that exist
so there's four different functions from
a single bit to a single bit two of them
are constant functions the other half
you know well they're not constantly
either doing nothing or they're flipping
the bit okay keeping that in mind
the goal of the problem is
the gain that you want to place the
following you're given or maybe david
deutsch gives you a such a fun you know
black box access oracle access to such a
function and you have to decide if it's
a constant function or not okay so the
goal is
decide
if such a function on a single bit
is constant
or not okay
um so the input just to be very precise
it's
oracle
access to a function
on a single bit
which is exactly you know
you can interpret in the way we
discussed it before and if you want to
be super picky about the output right
maybe we want that the output is
let's say
zero if
the function is a constant function
and one
if f is not constant so otherwise
okay
so last thing we want to discuss today
is
how well can you do with an ordinary
classical algorithm okay
and i want to have again right we end
this
in this
setting of
oracle problems so
basically we play a game i have a
function mind you get to ask me
questions
there's only two questions f zero and f
of one right that's the only thing you
can ask me can i say what's the function
value at zero what's the function of it
one
and i wanna understand uh i would like
you to think about what's the query
complexity of this problem that is how
many such questions you need to ask me
in any case in this case to figure out
if the function is constant or not okay
does anyone have a thought about this
reaction or maybe a clarification
question about how how the game works
so you can imagine i i am this box you
get to ask me questions you tell me in x
i tell you f of x and your goal is to
figure out whether i represent a
constant function
or whether i represent one of these
other two functions
you know to get a result with certainty
two
that's right so why um
i guess two because if you ask two
questions you know the function anyways
right the whole function yes but if i
ask you if i give you the zero and you
tell me zero then it could be that like
the identity but it could also be a
constant
uh whereas i could be lucky and i tell
you zero and you tell me one then i know
that i know that could also be the
constant function so i have to ask you
two times yeah i could not do that right
yeah you're completely right right from
an information point of view knowing one
function value does not is completely
independent from the other so knowing f
of zero is completely independent from f
of one but the property of being
constant depends on both right in in a
non-trivial way i mean basically by
checking that f of zero equals f one so
just knowing f of zero does not tell you
anything about constantness just knowing
f of one does not tell you anything
about constants so you need at least two
and two is enough because the function
is fully specified by two so that's
exactly right
so um clearly and now now we can boldly
say clearly because we have this nice
discussion
any classical algorithm and randomness
does not help
any classical algorithm
we'll need two queries
okay
we have to ask the this black box two
questions okay
and what we'll find next time is so next
time we'll discuss okay about the
natural questions can a quantum argument
do better
uh in order to answer this question we
have to ask what even is a quantum
oracle right right now i just know x
goes to f of x but what happens if i put
in cat 0 plus cat one what should that
do should it be kept f of zero plus cat
f of one does that make sense so we have
to have a little discussion about this
but then the upshot will be that there
is a quantum
which can solve the same problem using a
single query so we use this black box
that's oracle only once okay of course
we use it in a more general way and then
we have to discuss am i cheating and
we're not cheating i'll convince you
that we're not cheating
we can discuss about the importance of
this particular problem um but sort of
the answer basically roughly speaking
will be the following
um
whenever you have a
black box so whenever you open the black
box okay inside this is actually little
circuit
there's a completely mechanical
procedure that replaces the circuit by
quantum circuit of the same complexity
up to a negligible overhead uh that
implements this seemingly more powerful
oracle so i'm saying this was under
because he was skeptical about that we
are not cheating and so that's the
reason okay so that's that's a very good
explanation why this is fair i mean the
other question is of course that you
know in this particular problem the cost
will be anyways dominated by this box
you know not the number one or two well
maybe not so be important so you want to
of course also discuss more general
problems where there's actually
something that can large maybe where
there's an exponential separation
between cluster and quantum and so on
and so forth okay and of course to you
know to really give
proof something very convincing here
that's you know as hard as proven say p
versus np so you know we
you know we're working on it okay
so um but but sort of in this oracle
setting we can make very precise
statements very precise separations and
i think also very convincing ones
and um yeah so maybe that's a good way
of
of stopping here and maybe just asking
you for
for questions or feedback or thoughts
well first of all let's thank mikhail
that was fantastic i really appreciate
it
thanks